TUCKER CARLSON IS IN D.C.
AND HE IS UP NEXT.
♪ FILIBUSTER
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
AS YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS FIRED
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
MCCABE.
IF YOU HAVEN'T HEARD WELCOME
BACK TO NEW ZEALAND THIS IS
THE BIGGEST NEWS STORY IN
AMERICA.
THE PRESIDENT FIRED HIM ON A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
FBI'S CAREER INTERNAL
INVESTIGATORS AND DESPITE
ALL THE ATTENTION THIS
FIRING IS GETTING, AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT MUCH.
MCCABE WAS SET TO RETIRE IN
DAYS ANYWAY.
AND CONTRARY TO NEWS REPORTS
IS HE NOT AT RISK OF LOSING
MOST OF HIS ENORMOUS FEDERAL
PENSION, MUCH BIGGER THAN
THE PENSION YOU ARE NOT
GETTING.
NONE OF THIS HAS STOPPED THE
USUAL HYSTERIA MERCHANTS
FROM PREDICTING THE END OF
THE REPUBLIC.
SOME HAVE ACCUSED THE WHITE
HOUSE OF OBSTRUCTING
JUSTICE.
IT'S HARD TO SEE HOW THAT
WORKS EXACTLY SINCE MCCABE
WAS LEAVING ANYWAY.
OTHERS CALLED THE FIRING AN
ASSAULT ON DEMOCRACY AS IF
UNELECTED CAREER BUREAUCRATS
FOUND GUILTY OF MISCONDUCT
BY THEIR OWN AGENCIES WERE
SOMEHOW THE LINCHPIN OF
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT.
ONCE AGAIN NOT ONLY DUMB AGAIN H
ONCE AGAIN NOT ONLY DUMB AGAIN W
ONCE AGAIN NOT ONLY DUMB AGAIN D
ONCE AGAIN NOT ONLY DUMB AGAIN O
ONCE AGAIN NOT ONLY DUMB AGAIN A
ONCE AGAIN NOT ONLY DUMB AGAIN L
ONCE AGAIN NOT ONLY DUMB AGAIN T
ONCE AGAIN NOT ONLY DUMB AGAIN E
DUMB PEOPLE GET JOBS ON
TELEVISION.
THAT'S FOR ANOTHER SHOW.
DID ANDREW MCCABE DO
ANYTHING WRONG?
AND, TWO, IF SO, DID IT
JUSTIFY HIS FIRING?
WELL, ACCORDING TO THE FBI'S
OFFICE OF SPECIAL
RESPONSIBILITY, MCCABE ALOUD
FBI AGENTS TO DISCLOSE
SENSITIVE INFORMATION TO THE
PRESS.
LEAKED.
HE THEN LIED FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS ABOUT WHAT HE
DID.
THAT'S WHAT THE
INVESTIGATION FOUND.
NOW, IF MCCABE REALLY DID
THAT, LOSING HIS PENSION
OUGHT TO BE THE LEAST OF HIS
WORRIES BECAUSE LYING TO THE
FBI IS A FELONY, TRY IT AND
FIND OUT.
MARTHA STEWART WENT TO
PRISON FOR THAT MICHAEL
FLYNN HAD HIS LIFE DESTROYED
OVER IT.
MERE MORALITIES ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO LIE TO THE FBI.
THEY WILL WIND UP IN HAND
CUFFS WHEN THEY DO.
OF COURSE, IT'S A FAR
GREATER THREAT TO ALL OF US
WHEN FBI OFFICIALS LIE.
THE FBI IS THE MOST POWERFUL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN
THE WORLD.
IT HAS NEAR ABSOLUTE POWER
OVER YOU, THE POWER OF LIFE
AND DEATH.
YET, WEIRDLY NOBODY ON CNN
SEEMS BOTHERED IN THE
SLIGHTEST BY ANY OF THIS.
ONE OF THE FBI'S TOP
OFFICIALS CAUGHT LYING ABOUT
AN ACTIVE INVESTIGATION?
WHATEVER.
NO BIG DEAL.
PUNISHING HIM IS THE CRIME
HERE.
THAT'S AN ODD RESPONSE IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
CNN OPINIONIST SHOW CONCERN
I DON'T KNOW IF A LOCAL
SHERIFF LIED IN ORDER TO
FRAME TEENAGERS FOR CRIMES
THEY DIDN'T COMMIT?
HOW ABOUT IF YOUR LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENT FABRICATED
EVIDENCE?
DISHONEST SLAWMPLET A BIG
DEAL, NO MATTER WHO THE
PRESIDENT IS?
IN FACT IT'S THE BIGGEST
DEAL.
IT'S THE WORST ABUSE OF
POWER.
AND, YET, FOR SOME REASON
OUR DESIGNATED WATCHDOGS,
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE PROTECTING US
FROM THIS KIND OF THIRD
WORLD NONSENSE THINK IT'S
TOTALLY FINE AS LONG AS THE
NET RESULT IS A BAD NEWS
CYCLE FOR TRUMP.
WATCH.
>> THIS KIND OF THING THAT
WE SAW WITH RESPECT TO
ANDREW MCCABE IS THE KIND OF
THING YOU WOULD EXPECT PUTIN
TO DO.
>> MY PROBLEM IS THE TIMING
AND THE WAY IT ALL WORKED.
IT JUST SEEMED MEAN
SPIRITED.
>> THE POINT IS TO TEAR DOWN
THE CREDIBILITY OF ALL
PEOPLE INVOLVED WITH
ANYTHING PERTAINING TO
ANYTHING THAT MIGHT LOOK
INTO THIS PRESIDENT.
WHICH LEADS ONE TO BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS AUTHORITARIAN
BEHAVIOR.
>> THERE ARE KIDS GETTING
SHOT IN OUR SCHOOLS.
THERE IS AN EPIDEMIC OF
PEOPLE DYING FROM OVERDOSES.
AND WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT
MINDING, THESE LITTLE
VINDICTIVE SMALL LET'S GET
RID OF MCCABE AND DENY HIM
HIS PENSION.
>> Tucker: WHETHER YOU AGREE
OR NOT, POLITICS OF THE
PEOPLE YOU JUST SAW THOSE
ARE BUFFOONISH POINTS.
HERE IS SOMETHING NOT
BUFFOONISH THOUGH.
OVER THE WEEKEND THE FORMER
HEAD OF THE CIA JOHN BRENNAN
CAME COMPLETELY UNGLUED OVER
MCCABE'S FIRING ON TWITTER.
THAT'S THE PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE GO TO LOSE THEIR
MIND.
WHEN THE FULLEST EXTENT OF
YOUR VENALLALITY, BECOMES
KNOWN YOU WILL TAKE YOUR
RIGHTFUL PLACE AS A
DISGRACED DEMAGOGUE IN THE
DUST BIN OF HISTORY.
FINGER SMOKING HE'S TYPES IT
BUT HERE IS THE INTERESTING
PART.
IN RESPONSE TO THAT
BRENNAN'S TWEET, THE ONE YOU
JUST HEARD, FORMER U.N.
AMBASSADOR SAMANTHA POWER
WROTE, THIS QUOTE:  NOT A
GOOD IDEA TO PISS OFF JOHN
BRENNAN.
LET THAT SINK.
IN WHAT THE HELL DOES THAT
MEAN?
FORMER HEAD OF THE CIA IS
GOING TO DO WHAT EXACTLY IN
RESPONSE?
NO WONDER PEOPLE ARE AFRAID
OF THE DEEP STATE.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
WHEN IT BEARS ITS FANGS.
THWART US AND WE'LL DESTROY
YOU.
IN CASE YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
A REAL THREAT TO AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY AND THERE ARE
SOME.
THERE YOU GO.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ AEMERITUS
PROFESSOR AT HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
INVESTIGATORS ARE CORRUPT
AND LYING OR ANDREW MCCABE,
THE FORMER DEPUTY DIRECTOR
IS CORRUPT AND LYING.
ARE THERE OTHER OPTIONS AND
IF SO WHICH ONE OF THOSE IS
RIGHT?
>> WELL, IT'S A VERY SIMPLE
WAY OF FINDING OUT.
LET MCCABE WAVE HIS RIGHT OF
PRIVACY AND DEMAND THAT THE
PUBLIC SEE THE OFFICE OF
INVESTIGATION REPORT, THE
OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY REPORT.
THEN WE CAN DECIDE FOR
OURSELVES WHETHER OR NOT
THIS WAS A CORRUPT
INVESTIGATION OR WHETHER OR
NOT, IN FACT, MCCABE IS
GUILTY OF WHAT I HAVE CALLED
LYING AND COMEY IS GUILTY OF
TEST LYING.
THEIR TESTIMONY CONFLICTS.
MCCABE SAYS HE WAS
AUTHORIZED TO MAKE THE LEAK
BY THE HEAD OF THE FBI.
AND THE HEAD OF THE FBI HAS
SAID UNDER OATH THAT HE HAS
NEVER AUTHORIZED ANYBODY TO
MAKE A LEAK.
SO, THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF
TESTA LYING ON FRONT PAGE OF
THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
YESTERDAY IS FRONT AND
CENTER.
WHEN THE GUARDIANS NEED TO
HAVE GUARDIANS.
WHEN THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO PROTECT US ARE
TESTI LYING.
TESTIFYING FALSELY WE HAVE
THE RIGHT TO KNOW THAT.
>> Tucker: ABSOLUTELY WE
WANT TO LIVE IN A COUNTRY
WHERE WE CAN TRUST OUR MOST
BASIC INSTITUTIONS LIKE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND JUDICIARY.
PUT THIS IN CONTEXT FOR US.
I DON'T KNOW I HAVE NOT SEEN
THE REPORT.
I'M TAKING IT AS FACE VALUE
AND MAYBE I SHOULDN'T.
THE REAL CONCERN IS THAT THE
ALLEGATION IS A VERY SERIOUS
ONE.
THAT THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE FBI MIGHT BE LYING ABOUT
A CURRENT CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
WHY ARE SO MANY OTHERS
DISMISSIVE OF THAT LIKE IT'S
NO BIG DEAL?
LARRY, YOUR FORMER COLLEAGUE
AT HARVARD, FOR EXAMPLE.
WHY?
>> BECAUSE EVERYBODY IS SO
INVOLVED IN THIS PARTISAN
CONFLICT THAT ANYTHING
THAT'S DONE AGAINST TRUMP
MUST BE GOOD ACCORDING TO
THE PARTISANS ON ONE SIDE
AND ANYTHING DONE AGAINST
TRUMP MUST BE BAD ACCORDING
TO THE PARTISANS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
REMEMBER FROM, DAY ONE I
SAID DO NOT APPOINT A
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
HAVE A NONPARTISAN
INVESTIGATIVE COMMISSION
LIKE THE COMMISSION OF 9/11
THAT HAS INCREDIBLE TRUST
AND THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
PARTISAN DOG IN THIS RACE.
AND THEY HAVE TO BE THE ONES
TO MAKE THIS DECISION.
RIGHT NOW, THE FBI HAS LOST
ITS CREDIBILITY.
THE CIA IS LOSING ITS
CREDIBILITY.
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES
AREN'T TRUSTED BY EITHER
SIDE.
IT'S NOT TOO LATE TO CONVENE
A NONPARTISAN
CONGRESSIONALLY AUTHORIZED
INVESTIGATIVE COMMISSION TO
LOOK INTO WHETHER THERE WAS
COLLUSION WHETHER THE
RUSSIANS TRIED INTERFERE.
OF COURSE THEY DID.
WE NEED TO HAVE THE EVIDENCE
AND HOW TO STOP THEM FROM
DOING IT AGAIN.
THAT'S WHAT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC IS INTERESTED IN.
NOT FINGER POINTING BY BOTH
SIDES.
>> Tucker: LET QUICKLY TAKE
TRUMP OUT OF THIS.
IF YOU COULD SEND A MESSAGE
TO LIFELONG LIBERALS THAT
CARE ABOUT STAKES HERE.
WHAT WOULD IT BE LIKE TO
LIVE IN A COUNTRY WHERE THE
CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
WAS CORRUPT WHERE CHIEF
OFFICERS WERE LYING ABOUT
INVESTIGATIONS.
HOW WOULD THAT AFFECT
LIBERALS DOWN THE ROAD.
>> I HAVE A MESSAGE FOR BOTH
SIDES.
HIIVELGLY IT'S BEEN THE
LIBERALS AND DEMOCRATS WHO
HAVEN'T TRUSTED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND HAVE SAID LET'S MAKE
SURE WE HAVE OVERSIGHT.
IT'S BEEN THE REPUBLICANS
AND CONSERVATIVES AND SAID
OH, ANYTHING THE FBI SAYS
HAS TO BE CORRECT OR TRUE
EVEN JAY HE
EVEN J.Y HE
EVEN J. EHE
EVEN J. EDGAR HOAR.
WE HAVE SEEN
HO HAVE SEEN
HOOVAVE SEEN
HOOVERE SEEN
HOOVER. SEEN
MY MESSAGE TO BOTH DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS IS GET BACK
TO PRINCIPLE AND STOP THIS
PARTISANSHIP.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC IS
INTERESTED AND CARES ABOUT
THE TRUTH FROM A NONPARTISAN
POINT OF VIEW.
THEY ARE SICK AND TIRED OF A
REPUBLICAN TRUTH, A DEMOCRAT
TRUTH, A TRUMP TRUTH AND
ANTI-TRUMP TRUTH.
WE NEED THE TRUTH IN A FLAWN
PARTISAN WAY.